tu m'a ouvert les yeux tu as guider mais
je dis moi ce que tu veux je t'aimerai
toujours tellement j'ai d'amour
toi
il ya près de deux mois soit vécue de 17
ton père ap paris mme bélanger quelques
semaines plus tard franchi le cap des 50
ans parce que c'est l'heure des bilans
gregory charles
il y ait aucun doute pense pour inventer
quoi que ce soit mais je pense que les
gens qu importe quand on perd nos bas 7
ce concept d'éternité que nous avions
disparaît et on devient en plus de
perdre des gens qu'on aime donc calme on
passe de notre colloque en plus c'est
encore plus difficile mais c'est de ne
pas deviner habilité qui nous a mis en
pleine face toute ma vie j'ai passé mes
parents étaient éternels je les ai vus
j'ai vu ma mère décline en plusieurs
zones effectué s'habitue à l'idée que
éventuellement au passé tant que mon
père comme c'était subi accidentelle
catastrophique absolument est prévue
c'est sûr que ça remue mais en même
temps moi qui souhaitais pas trop passer
mon cinquantième anniversaire
mais c'est un événement qui me fait
penser à autre chose c'est c'est sûr des
fois tu as pas du goût de juste la
couleur peut déjà prendre une pause
la réponse c gepa wittmann une pause
mais oui je suis au moment où ses pattes
à ralentir que de courir moins de
courses en même temps et je pense l'avim
dans tous ces indices mais aussi en même
temps les deuils combine ça serve aux
siestes mes parents qui pensent
éternelle ne l'étaient pas ils sont
maintenant partis je suis un orphelin
ils n'ont pas manqué leur vie ils n'ont
pas manqué non plus les voyages ensemble
je permis de ralentir certaines courses
pour laisser davantage de deux places à
la faillite et la célébration jeune
fille de 6 ans c'est fantastique ce
qu'elle veut faire ce qu'elle apprend ce
qu'est le parlement qui soit non plus à
spectacle j'ai envie de ralentir j'ai
envie de faire un peu - enfin - des
courses j'ai sur le paysage est un film
en plus beau quand on le regarde
un peu moins vite mais avouons que c'est
extrêmement livre de faire de la vitesse
descente et lula quatre ont reposé
d'arrêter la satisfaction qu'on a quand
on a forcé dur pour se rendre jusqu'au
jusqu'au sommet pourrait ensuite prendre
la pente descendante les deux jours par
semaine
[Musique]
rigueur et chercher du million de
billets vendus 1 millions de disques
vendus
mais en juin 2016 une des articles là
dessus d'ailleurs je vous avais cherché
10 millions de dollars auprès de tes
proches pour renflouer les coffres est
ce que maintenant ça va mieux ce que tu
vois la lumière au bout du tunnel
oui ça va mieux géré on a même dépassé
le bout du tunnel n'est pas une question
de lumière ou bourrelet vraiment dépassé
le tunnel mais moi j'ai vraiment frappé
j'ai frappé un hindou dan
je me suis ramassé avec
avec des échéances que je n'avais pas
prévu et je cherchais des solutions
pendant un long moment je vous ai appris
beaucoup joué mais j'ai une solution
institutionnelle par les mamans pour
finir par trouver une solution familiale
une solution d'equipe c'est probablement
la leçon la plus importante mots que
j'ai que je vais avoir tiré de la vie et
pourtant mes parents me le disait que la
chose qui t'a plus importante le succès
de l'équipe de succès mais ces prix
avaient une habitude de réussir par mois
mais jusqu'à ce que a presque vers la
fin le presque au bord d'une on peut
presque au bord du précipice je prenne
un téléphone pour dire j'ai vraiment
besoin dead et qu'on dise veille ont
fait passer quelques galeries de réponse
est oui oui je vous explique henno
explique nous pas mes beaux parents par
exemple bondi
explique-nous organisation nous avons
monté à voir en famille on te dit on
faisait mettre la partie de l'équipe
grégory et l'équipe grégory ben ça m'a
permis de sortir de ce tunnel dont on
entend parler c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé c'est vraiment très touchant
litres et très touchant je me sens
rempli de ce que j'ai vécu de ce que
j'ai eu comme comme soutien comme
expérience
et moi qui commence mon deuxième
de mon deuxième demi siècle je me sens
totalement engagé énergique enthousiaste
à l'idée de remettre ce que j'ai reçus
puis de consacrer mais quand cela
prendre des chances a essayé des choses
en ayant la ferme volonté de réussir
mais en sachant que quand tu essaies des
affaires peut tromper
merci beaucoup merci